for the past few weeks Nate Tannenbaum  who you see right here has transformed  from traffic anchor to flute  extraordinaire and this week a you've  got another item on tap for us I sure do  now so I've been trying to play songs  that I hope fit the mood and try to  lighten the mood last week try to have  some fun with a social distancing song  that stings don't stand so close for  today I want to honor everyone who works  in all of the hospitals and all the  first responders who are putting  themselves in danger to keep all of us  safe during the pandemic now this song  was originally recorded by Bette Midler  it was in the movie beaches see if you  can name that tune  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  so to all the medical workers and first  responders you are the wind beneath all  of our way oh good job mate that was  beautiful yes thank you guys nice way to  end the week we'll see you on Monday CBS  this morning starts right now again  [Music]